- Hello and welcome to Khan
Academy live SAT class.
My name is Eric, I'm an SAT tutor
and one of the SAT experts
here at Khan Academy.
This is class number two of three
that we have planned for the
SAT over the next few weeks
and I'm very excited to be
covering SAT Reading today.
Before we jump into SAT Reading,
I want to give you a preview
of what we're going to cover
today and next week, let's take a look.
So last week we covered SAT
Math, in our first class,
and if you missed that class, don't worry,
we recorded it and you can
find it on our YouTube channel
so go ahead and check that
out if you're interested
and today, like I mentioned,
we're gonna cover SAT Reading
and then the following week,
we'll cover SAT Writing
and all of these classes
will be at the same times,
so Thursday, they'll all be on Thursdays
at 7pm Eastern, 4pm Pacific,
so these are all the classes
that we'll have planned
and for today, let's take a look
at what we'll cover for SAT Reading.
So for today's class, the first 25 minutes
I'll spend giving some instruction
and doing some practice problems together.
Specifically, I'm going
to introduce a strategy
called Rephrase & Predict,
which is a more proactive approach,
that you can use for SAT Reading questions
that I found really helpful
and that many students
find helpful to try.
Next, I'll cover Words in Context problems
and Command of Evidence problems as well
and we'll do some practice
problems together.
Then, in the next 10 minutes,
I will answer some student questions,
and so at that point, you'll have a chance
to add comments in YouTube
and I'll try and answer
as many questions as I can
in the time that I have,
I'll give out the Khan
Academy badge and all of that
and then in the last 25 minutes,
you'll practice what you've
learned on Khan Academy
and just like last class, we have a number
of Khan Academy and College
Board experts available
to help you while you have questions.
Unlike last class, after
the instruction and Q&A,
I'll sign off and you'll just head
to Khan Academy to practice.
You won't need to come back
to YouTube this time around
so you'll spend 35 minutes on YouTube
and then, in the next
25 minutes, practice,
do reading problems and we'll be there
to help via one-on-one chat.
So, let's take a look at
what we're gonna cover
and get started.
So why are we talking about proactive
reading strategies today?
Well, let me pose a few questions
and let me know if any
of these sound familiar
or if you've ever been in
this kind of situation before.
So, have you ever read the answer choices
and thought, well, all of these look good,
and, you know, you're kind of stuck there?
Or, maybe you get the
question down to two choices
but then end up picking the wrong one,
or you're always 50-50 and
not sure which one to pick?
Or maybe you're like I
was, when I first started
practicing for the SAT Reading
and maybe you run out of time
on the SAT Reading section?
Well, that's why we're chatting
about the Rephrase & Predict strategy.
So this strategy is one that I found
that was really helpful for me
and helpful for a number of students
and so, I'd recommend giving it a try,
it's certainly not the
only way to approach
SAT Reading questions but it's,
it can be really helpful
once you get the hang of it,
when you are approaching
SAT Reading questions.
So this strategy really focuses
on coming up with your own
answer to reading questions
before you look at the answer choices.
So this is the most important word, before
and there are really two parts,
so this first part, involves,
is called the Rephrase portion
and this part involves
reading the question
but covering the answer choices
and this is really important,
so that you don't distract yourself
with the answer choices up front
and then if possible,
rephrase the question
into a how, what or why question,
and this can really help
simplify the question
to put it in your own words
and can just make sure
that you understand the
question before you move on.
The next step in this
strategy is to predict
and so you would start by reviewing
the relevant parts of the passage,
so go back and re-read
a little bit before,
a little bit after where you need to
and then, based on
that, predict the answer
to the question in your own words
and so if the question is asking
the author's purpose in paragraph two is,
you would actually say, in your own words,
well I think it was to
introduce amphibians
as a relevant population
for this biological study,
so you would say something
in your own words
to answer the question.
Then, and only then, would
you uncover the answer choices
and then start crossing out the choices
that don't match your prediction
and select the choice that best matches,
and so, instead of a different approach
of reading the question,
looking at the answer choices
and then evaluating one by one,
you come up with your own prediction first
and then that really can help
when you do finally look
at the answer choices
and it can help you hone in on the ones
that match your prediction and
are supported by the passage
and eliminate the ones
that might look plausible
but once you have that
prediction in your mind
of, oh, well, I think the
answer is this amphibian thing,
it's easier to do that matching
and to hone in on the right question.
So let's take a look
at what this looks like
for a practice problem now,
just to make it a little
more tangible and real.
So, step one, if you're
watching from home,
is to take your hand, right
hand, left hand, whichever one
and cover up answer choices A through D,
so go ahead and cover
up those answer choices
and now, we'll do the Rephrase
part of that strategy.
So, as used in line three,
vent most nearly means,
and so this is a more
straightforward question
but it is just, essentially,
we could rephrase it
to what does vent mean
and now, if I had the passage,
I would go back to the passage,
read a little bit around the word vent,
gather some context clues,
and then say my prediction
for the second part of the strategy
was that vent meant gap, and
so I'd write down my prediction
or just say it in my head,
and then, and only then,
so you can lift up your hand now,
would I look at the answer choices,
and at that point, with gap in mind,
it's a bit easier to eliminate
some of the answer choices
that don't match, and narrow
it down to the ones that do.
So, for example, gap
doesn't fit passage as well,
doesn't fit outlet as
well, and then I'm down
to opening and crack, and in the real SAT
I would go into the reading passage,
gather some context clues and
see what I'm finding there.
So, that's an example of how
this Rephrase and Predict strategy looks
for a standalone sample problem
and later in class we're
gonna apply this strategy
in a real SAT reading
passage with a few questions
just so you get used to it.
But before we do that, I want
to cover Words in Context
and Command of Evidence problems,
which are two common problems
that you'll see in the SAT Reading.
So Words in Context questions,
what are these exactly?
So these problems measure
your understanding
of the meaning and use
of words and phrases
in the context of passages
and this word, context,
is the most important part.
And so these questions don't
ask you to define words,
you might know the meaning
of words in day to day life
like determination, but what
makes these questions unique
is that the context of
the passage is crucial
and so you wanna look a little bit before
and after and around the word,
so that you can gather
the surrounding words,
ideas and circumstances to pick up
on how the author is using the word
in the passage and what it means.
And so there are two specific types
of Words in Context
questions and the first one,
is interpreting words
and phrases in context.
So these questions ask you
what word or phrase means
as used in the passage,
and so that's very much
like the sample problem we
did around the word vent
as used in line three, most nearly means
and so you're probably
familiar with these.
The next type asks you
how the author's choice of
words affects the passage
and affects the meaning, tone and style.
So if this first question type
is more of a what question,
this second question type is
more of a purpose or impact,
is one helpful way of thinking about it.
So we'll take a look at these
Words in Context problems
later in class but this should
give you a good overview
of the types of Words in Context questions
you might see on the SAT
on the Reading section
and also in the Writing Section,
so let's keep going now
to Command of Evidence.
So Command of Evidence
questions are designed
to see whether you
understand how an author
uses evidence to support a claim
or argument or point that they're making
and this is a skill
that's tested on the SAT
because it's really crucial in college,
in the workforce, you
know, once you graduate,
or in day to day life and so it really is
very applicable to creating arguments,
defending arguments, evaluating them
and on the SAT, how will they show up?
Well, there are three
types of evidence questions
that you'll see, and so
the first one asks you
to determine the best type of evidence,
so it'll ask you what textual evidence
provides the best support or,
the other type of question
here, will show up in pairs
where it'll ask you what is
the main point of paragraph one
and then the second question will ask you
what evidence best supports
your answer to the first question.
Now, the second type of question
under the evidence section
will ask you to interpret data
in graphics of different kinds
and it'll ask you to look at the graphic,
understand it and how it
relates to the passage
and any claims the author may be making.
Now, a tip I would have here,
would be to break down
the graph piece by piece,
so rather than trying to
understand it all at once,
ask yourself just one
simple question at a time,
so that you build up your
understanding from the ground up
and so you could ask what is the title,
and what is it telling me?
You could ask about the axes next,
and so the axes and units,
you might look at the key,
and all of these questions will
help you build to the point
where you can state, in your own words,
this graph is showing me the distribution
of fir trees around California.
Now, the third and final
type of evidence question
asks you how an argument uses
or doesn't use specific
pieces of evidence,
so those are things like
facts, figures, quotations,
and how that influences
the author's claims
or arguments that they're making.
So, there were was a lot of
information to take in up front,
but let's now apply what
we've discussed so far
on the Rephrase & Predict strategy,
Words in Context questions
and the Command of Evidence questions,
within a real SAT passage.
So let's get some practice together
before you head off to Khan
Academy to practice yourself.
Oop, let me zoom out a little bit here.
So, before I start,
before we start going
through this passage,
I just wanna share that how we
go through the passage today
might be a little bit different
from how you would do this if
you were by yourself at home
and it's just because I'm on a computer
and so it's harder,
it's just a little hard
for me to show you all
of the passage at once
and so, just for today,
as we walk through it,
we'll go through this a
few paragraphs at a time
and bounce back and forth
between the questions
but how you would do this at home,
might look a little bit different, okay?
So let's take a look, let's
go ahead and read the passage
just up to this point
here and then we'll pause.
So let's go ahead and do that.
This passage is excerpted
from Kasley Killam,
A Hug A Day Keeps the Doctor Away, okay.
Scientific American, okay,
so looks like a study.
So, during my final semester
of undergrad, I made two signs
that read, feeling stressed
about exams, have a free hug!
Then I recruited a friend and we stood
in the entrance of the campus library,
held up the signs, and waited.
Passersby had one of two reactions,
either they quickly looked
down at their phones
and awkwardly shuffled by,
or their faces lit up as they embraced us.
Most people were enthusiastic.
Some exclaimed, "You made my day!"
Or "thank you, I needed this."
One leapt into my arms,
nearly toppling me over.
After two hours of warm interactions,
my friend and I couldn't believe
how energized and happy we felt.
Okay, so let me go through that again
and just mark up a few important things,
so, feeling stressed about
exams, have a free hug,
and they had warm interactions
and then, at the end,
they were feeling pretty
energized and happy,
so then this seems like
just a story about how,
at the end of this person's
undergrad career, okay.
So let's read the next paragraph now.
A study published earlier this month
suggests that, in addition to making us
feel connected to others,
all those hugs may have
prevented us from getting sick,
okay, so that seems important
and this is the topic
sentence of the paragraph
so worth paying a little
more attention to.
At first, this finding probably
seems counterintuitive,
not to mention bizarre.
You might think, like I did,
that hugging hundreds of strangers,
hugging strangers would
increase your exposure to germs
and therefore the likelihood
of falling ill, okay.
But, we've got a but here,
so but words, contrast words
are very important, and often
signal a shift in the passage
so, but, the new research
out of Carnegie Mellon
indicates that feeling connected
especially through physical touch,
protects us from stress-induced sickness.
Okay, so this research adds
to a large amount of evidence
for the positive influence
of social support on health.
Okay, so just to confirm that
I understand this passage,
we've got a topic sentence
that said feeling connected
to others seems to have
these health benefits
and hugging a lot of people,
rather than exposing
you to germs, actually,
according to the Carnegie
Mellon study offers
some protection against
stress-induced sickness, okay.
Okay, so I think I understand that,
and what you'll notice, as
I was reading the passage,
was that I was pretty actively writing
and underlining and making
sure that I understood
what I was reading as I went
and so there's an active reading article
that we have on Khan Academy
that would be great to check out
but that's how you can read
and make sure you
understand along the way,
to save yourself time,
so you aren't re-reading
as much as you go along.
So, we have the passage,
now let's look at the first question.
So here we're gonna use the
Rephrase & Predict strategy
that we mentioned, so again,
take your left hand or your right hand,
whichever non-dominant hand you have,
and go ahead and cover up A through D
and now we're gonna look at the questions.
So the first paragraph serves mainly to,
so we're just looking up until this part,
everything above this part,
and if I rephrase this,
this is just what is the
purpose of the first paragraph.
Okay, so I don't need to write that down
since it'll take me some time.
So what is the purpose
of the first paragraph?
Well, let's take a look
at the first paragraph
and probably a little bit of
context from the second as well
and that will inform my prediction
for what I think the answer is.
So, when I was reading
this passage earlier,
this seemed like the author's story
about something he did in
undergrad, about making signs
and mentioned how positive
this hugging experience was
and then, in the next paragraph,
we've got the study and the impact of hugs
and we get a little more scientific here
and so the first paragraph
serves mainly to,
or the purpose of the first paragraph,
my prediction here is going to be
that it was a story and then if we look
at the structure here,
we have the story here
and then we have the study here,
so that's kind of how
I'm thinking about it,
story that leads into the study
and so that's my prediction
and, as you can see,
it doesn't have to be super
sophisticated and complex,
in fact, if you have a good
understanding of the passage
the prediction is often pretty simple
and a few words is all that you need.
And so now, I can uncover the
answer choices A through D
and take a look at which
one matches my prediction
of the author used the
first paragraph as a story,
as a way of introducing and
giving background for the study.
So, let's take a look at the first one,
provide background information necessary
to understand the scientific study,
so that is not completely
off from what I mentioned
but not exactly what I said
either, so I'll leave that in
and then introduce the scientific study
through a personal anecdote.
Okay, so that's actually
very close to my prediction
since an anecdote is a story
and I mentioned this introduce piece
so that seems like the
top candidate so far.
But let's take a look at these other ones,
so show that not all
scientific experiments
need to be conducted in a laboratory.
Well, we're not talking, in the passage,
about all scientific experiments
and there's no mention of
a laboratory in the passage
so I can go ahead and cross that one out.
And then last one, describe
the author's experience
as the subject of the scientific study.
So, the first paragraph is more of a story
and the author actually doesn't mention
that it was a scientific study,
it was just more of
something that they did
in the last semester,
so this scientific study
will eliminate this, and so
B is really the best choice
that matches my
prediction, which was based
on the information that
I had in the passage.
So that's an example of
how Rephrase & Predict
is used in practice, it can
take some getting used to
but once you practice a little bit more,
you'll get faster and faster at that
and once you have the prediction,
going through the answer
choices will be a lot faster.
Now, the other thing I'll point out
is that as I was going
through the answer choices,
you might have seen me cross off
certain parts of answer choices,
and that was because the right answer
will be completely right
and supported by the passage
and if there is a part of an answer choice
that feels off or isn't
supported by the passage,
that's enough for me to cross it off
and so that just helps me eliminate
answer choices a little bit faster
and is another thing you can try.
So let's take a look at
some of the other questions
and keep on going.
So let's take a look,
in the second paragraph
the author implies that
the study shows hugs to be,
so now we're talking about this paragraph,
second paragraph, here.
Author implies that the
study shows hugs to be,
so this is, I can rephrase this to be
hugs to be question mark.
Okay, and again, I'm not looking
at the answer choices yet
since that will automatically
influence my thinking
and I'll start thinking well
maybe it's A, maybe it's D,
but before I have formed my own opinion,
I don't wanna do that
so let's take a look back
at the second paragraph
and look for the study
and what the author is
implying about that.
So, study published
earlier suggests that hugs
make us feel connected and
prevent us from getting sick,
and prevent us from getting sick
and then here's the study, here,
so new research out of Carnegie Mellon,
shows that feeling connected,
especially through physical touch,
protects us from stress-induced sickness.
So that is pretty positive, so hugs good,
is kind of the takeaway there
and so then my prediction
for what the author is saying
implies that the study shows about hugs,
is that hugs are good for health,
good for health and have
these health benefits
or have these protection,
will help protect us
from sickness, or protect from sickness.
And now, with that prediction
I can go ahead and
uncover the answer choices
and look through A through
D, so let's take a look.
A says that hugs are
the only proven method
of preventing sickness,
so only proven method,
makes that not correct, cos the study says
that there's some benefits of hugs
but certainly doesn't claim
that it's the only proven method,
and doesn't match my prediction
either, so let's keep going.
Less successful than social support
at protecting people from
colds and other illnesses.
So in this case, they're making
an interesting comparison here
about less successful than social support
and that's really not
something that's mentioned
in the second paragraph, and again,
doesn't match my prediction
based on the paragraph,
so this less successful
than social support,
there's no comparison that's
being made in that paragraph,
so we can go ahead and cross that out.
And then we have not
conclusively effective
at helping people maintain good health.
So this actually, the tone of this
is hugs are so-so, we're
not sure about hugs,
but this was, we have hugs good here,
we know hugs are good, even
if we didn't read the passage
so that not conclusively effective
is the opposite of what the
author's actually implying
and so D then, one of several ways
to guard against some illnesses.
Well, here's that part of my prediction,
so protect from illness, good for health,
and so therefore, my answer is D.
So, this was now an example of
a Command of Evidence problem
and how the Rephrase & Predict strategy
can be used in that context.
But, this is a two-parter,
so we're not done yet.
Let's head back in and
pinpoint the evidence
that matches and supports our answer.
So, which choice provides
the best evidence
for the answer to the previous question?
So, in this case, let's take a look,
we've got, again, so we're looking
for the best evidence here,
and let's go back and
look at the passage here,
and again, we're not looking
at the answer choices
and so, why did I choose D,
is essentially what the passage is saying
and what evidence from
the passage supports that
and so, this is about
the study showing hugs
and so, you can hone in here
on this hugs good section
and the study is mentioned here,
about Carnegie Mellon,
the Carnegie Mellon study about
physical touch protecting us
from stress-induced illness,
so that's a great thing,
and so I think that's really where,
where I made my decision there
and so then I can uncover
the answer choices
and, looks like answer
choice C is that answer.
And so, just for completion's sake,
I'll make sure to look through
some of these other ones
just to walk through,
but that matches exactly
what I was thinking
and my prediction about
the Carnegie Mellon study.
So, line 12 through 14, a study, sickness,
so a study published earlier
suggests that in addition
to making us feel connected
all these hugs may have
prevented us from getting sick,
so that one feels more like commentary
and oh, actually forgot
I posted this down here
so we can look down here too,
so that one is more of
commentary, so that one's out
and then 16 to 18, you
might think like I did
that hugging hundreds of strangers
would increase your exposure,
that again is more commentary
and isn't providing evidence and then D
is 21 to 23, this research adds
to a large amount of evidence here,
and again, that is not as strong
as the evidence presented here
that we're citing from Carnegie Mellon
so that one is out as well.
Okay, so now we've done
some Command of Evidence,
now let's take a look at a
Words in Context question
and that'll be the last
practice problem we do together
before we move on to a few other things.
Let's take a look at
the next paragraph here,
so it looks like we're looking here now,
from here to here, so social
support can broadly be defined
as the perception of
meaningful relationships
that serve as a psychological
resource during tough times.
More specifically, this
means emotional support,
such as expressions of compassion,
and may include access to
information or other assistance.
The researchers measured social support
by giving out a questionnaire
in which participants
rated different statements.
Then, they conducted interviews
every night for two weeks
to find out how often
participants experienced conflict
with others and how
often they received hugs.
Finally, the researchers
infected participants
with a common cold virus
and observed what happened.
So that part seems questionable,
I don't know about the ethics
of doing that last part
but this paragraph then
is saying social support,
what that means, and it looks
like it's emotional support
and expressions of compassion,
information and assistance
and then this was how they conducted
the rest of the experiment.
Okay, so then in line 27,
expressions most nearly means,
so what does expressions mean,
and so, more specifically,
this means emotional
support such as expressions
of compassion and may
include access to information
or other assistance, okay.
So I've taken into
consideration the context
and it seems like in this context,
it's expressions of compassion,
could also be stated as acts
of compassion or kindness
and so these are kind of
more physical behaviors
is gonna be my prediction
so then let's take a look
at what matches my prediction.
So, demonstrations, yep, that could be,
demonstrations are an acts of
kindness, seems pretty close.
Declarations of compassion,
that's more words
but I've got acts here,
so I don't think that one fits as well.
We've got revelations, so that's more,
that means something like discoveries
and we're not discovering
kindness here so that's out
and then looks of compassion,
also doesn't quite fit
since I am all about acts of compassion
and so demonstrations of compassion
really is what fits best.
So this was the last practice
problem that we'll do together
and if you wanna re-watch any
of what we've gone through,
we'll send out the recording again
but now, it's time to do some,
I'm gonna answer a few student questions
and so, if you have any questions,
go ahead and put them into
the YouTube comments now
and then I'll answer as many as I can
before we head over to Khan Academy
to practice what we've learned.
So, take a minute to do
that as I get set up here.
Okay, so we've got a few questions
from students here so let me take a look.
First question, are there deducted points
for incorrect answers on the SAT?
So, answer to that is no,
so there is no guessing penalty on the SAT
on any of the sections and so that means
if you're not sure of the right answer
for a question, you should always guess
and so that goes for multiple choice,
for free response in the Math section,
and so you should always guess
since there is no guessing penalty.
Let's see, another question we got
is are the SAT practice tests
on par with the real tests?
Like if I score a 1300
on the practice test,
would I expect to score that on the SAT?
Well, assuming you're talking
about the practice tests
on official SAT practice, on Khan Academy,
those practice tests
are official SAT tests
released by College Board and
are an accurate reflection
of what you can expect on the real SAT.
So if you find yourself
consistently scoring,
say, in the 1250 to 1300 range,
that is a pretty good
indication of what you'll get
and what you might find
on the real test day
but the only thing I would say is there,
on the real test day, there
might be a few factors
that aren't at play during practice tests
like nerves, or how well you slept,
or what you ate that day, so
it is a pretty good indication
but it might not be exactly perfect.
We got a question about general advice
on how to manage time, well,
the resource I'd direct you to there
is there are a handful of
articles on the Khan Academy
in our tips and strategies section,
that have tips for how
you can manage your time
on Math, Reading and Writing
and so I'd really give that
a thorough read through
and it really has everything
that I would tell you to do anyway
and I think we'll try and post that link
in the comments as well
but there are things like working through
some of the simpler problems first,
since all SAT questions are
worth the same number of points,
going through the easier
and medium questions
so that you have ample time for those
before you go to the harder questions,
is one way you can do it but
really check out those articles
for the best advice that we have on that.
We had a question, if your prediction
doesn't match the answers, does
that mean you read it wrong?
So that's a great question,
so say you had a prediction
that the word vent meant gap
and then it didn't match
anything in the answer choices,
what I would encourage you to do then,
is yes, to go back into the passage
and make sure you've considered
all of the context around the passage
and make sure you understand
that paragraph well enough
that you can restate
what the author is saying
and what the purpose of that
paragraph is in your own words
and if you can state it in your own words,
that is really a good check
to see if you understood
the author's point
and the argument or statement
that they were making
and so if your prediction doesn't match,
in that case yeah, I would
go back to the passage
and make sure you understood
what the author was saying
and then give that prediction another go.
Another way you could
approach it is to just look
at what the passage says
and the evidence there.
So the right answer in
SAT Reading questions
will have textual evidence to support it
and so you can work backwards a little bit
to look at the passage and
see, okay, what evidence
do I have to support one
of these answer choices?
Another question, should
I read the passage first
or read the questions first?
So that one, there are a lot
of different opinions on this
and I would say, it really comes down
to how you've practiced and
what you've found works well.
So some people will read
through and scan the questions
just so that they can
mark out in the passage
okay, I've got a question at line seven,
a question at line 53, and then I need
to notice a shift in tone somewhere
and so that, for some
students, they like to look
at what they're gonna be
asked so that they know
where to pay more attention
to in the passage.
Other students, they wanna just focus,
for other students a different approach
of reading the whole
passage, really understanding
and understanding each paragraph
and the author's argument and claims
and then looking at the
questions is easier,
so that they're just
focusing on understanding
and then going into the questions.
So I would really say practice, try both,
see which one works best
for you and go with that.
I just wouldn't, if you're
close to your test date,
don't change things up at the last minute.
Okay, so we have another good question,
if you're forced to skip
a question or guess,
and have enough time to go
back, should you go back to it
at the end of the passage problem set
or at the end of the reading portion?
So I would definitely say
at the end of the passage problem set,
so say you have questions one through 11
on a reading passage
and you skip number nine
cos you're like oh, I don't know,
it could be either of these,
once you get to question 11,
and you've finished all the
questions on that passage,
revisit question nine at that point
because it'll be easier for your brain
to stay within the mode of that passage
whereas if you wait til
the end of the passage,
you then have to remind yourself, okay,
what was this passage about?
And what was question nine asking?
So it'll just take you longer to do that.
So, we're coming up a
little bit on time now
and so, unfortunately all the
questions I can cover for now
but I'll cover more questions next time
and for now, I wanna
show you a few pointers
about practicing for
the SAT on Khan Academy,
the badge, one-on-one chat,
and all of that good stuff,
so let's take a look.
So, like I mentioned at the beginning,
we have people waiting to help you
if you run into any questions
and chat with you one-on-one
but a common question we
get, is what if I don't see
the one-on-one chat box on Khan Academy?
Well, one thing I want to point out
is that the one-on-one
chat is only available
on the SAT part, so make
sure your web address
looks something like
KhanAcademy.org/mission/SAT
and if you're not on a
URL that looks like that
then that's why the one-on-one
chat is not showing up.
The other thing you can try
is to try and refresh the page as well.
Now, when you head over to Khan Academy,
the first thing I'd recommend you do
is to explore a bit and then
do some practice problems.
So while we have those wonderful folks
who are volunteering their time to help,
the best thing you can do is start
by doing some practice problems yourself
and then if you get stuck, reach out.
In just a bit we're also
going to share the badge link
and so that'll show up in the comments
and for that you will sign
into your Khan Academy account
and then your badge will show
up in the top right corner,
oh, this is no longer right,
but there will be a notification
icon that you'll see there
and so we'll post the badge there
and so now, if you're familiar
with official SAT practice
on Khan Academy, go ahead
and head over there now
and sign into your Khan Academy account,
start practicing, and if you get stuck,
reach out to one of our amazing people
who are here to help you today.
If you're brand new to
official SAT practice,
I'm gonna do a quick walkthrough
of some of the key parts
just to get you started.
So, this is official SAT
practice on Khan Academy
and so you'll see this is the homepage,
and if I wanted to practice,
I'd just head over here
and click practice and
you'll see that I have Math,
Reading & Writing and
Essay portions as well
and for today, you'll
see that you can practice
any reading topic here, or if you wanted
to go to Writing & Language,
you can practice anything here as well.
Now, if you want a refresher
on a topic that you don't see here,
I'd really recommend you go
up here to the search bar
and type up a search, for say
quadratic equations, right?
So that's one thing you can do
and then if you have general
questions about the SAT,
the format, strategies you can use,
so time management, for example,
these are two great articles
that I mentioned before,
I would head here to go through
and get answers to those questions.
Let's take a look,
and I think that's most of
what I was going to cover,
so go ahead and head over, and then,
oh, the last thing I'll call out,
is this is where you'll see that chat box
and so you can just type in here,
ask a question, and we'll
get back to you as soon as,
reply as quickly as we can.
So, that's all I have
for you today on YouTube
and so now it's time to
head over to Khan Academy,
practice what you've
learned, if you get stuck
or have any questions, we're here to help.
For now, that's all we have for today
but I hope to see you next
Thursday at 7pm Eastern,
4pm Pacific, for our last and
final class on SAT Writing.
Thanks so much, and I
hope to see you next time.